back in the day under Thibodeau and
Chicago Kristin comments by him today
wasn't it about how most players would
have retired by now he turns it over
[Applause]
Bruder moon dumps it off for ferguson
Minsky's their trainer son of white
shipments here on another block by
harold stay with it
papaya
lottery with it last season Minnesota
30th in a tense meeting the drop off the
putter
the president ago the elephant's made a
difference so no be still them up there
getting ripped it or position my
expected to be contribute there's a
steal by Paul George took it right away
from Jackson anytime and not to pick on
it but anytime the Clippers what the
good teams around us what the good teams
do Aten goes over the top of outlet
Judas and then Leonard those strong
hands rips it away down the triple ties
it up at 35 always looking to do what
changing the turnovers under again just
like the first half bills out
[Applause]
defense tested here now Simmons be on
the back lose his head the liner with
the Pope letter right there here's
Pascal
and you take it you run their meal and
there's a turnover good pressure on the
ball ball George tweets hesitates to the
rabid dogs up above the rim for twenty
four point two the third Lillard into
the lane try to send a little bounce
backs into Leonard at close quarters
tipped away look
[Applause]
Winslow with it on a handoff to wide
diving takes it away from whale in the
defensive play
see I come right Richardson
Harris ones off rhythm couples will not
fall the rebound stolen the Manson is
Peverley on the defensive and stripped
it layering John Jackson blocked the
shot down the turnover
kanan snags it Rizza he got blocked on
the other end by Paul George Smith over
to Pachulia John a dribble handoff
knocked away by Leonard loose ball if
you're the Clippers right now want to
speed up the pace of this game right now
Green blocked from behind by Harold Luke
to the paint fast back outside picked
off by Paul George George with a drive
and a scoop and a score there Ronnie
thing with Butler is that his chandler
way outside Butler right there blocked
by Kawhi Leonard just over a minute
remaining
[Applause]
ball deflected away don't run away I had
to Bradley drive to the hole Jeffers
Lane something with that blade
how did tear his Ferguson know to step
out like that is that the players edges
appeal for the game speaking of feel for
the basketball another block and
heirlooms in transition throws it down
up around that three-point arc down to
by 9
here's Evans has it knocked away
stripped by Kawhi
Ricky - Donovan take it up young fella
in traffic and Paul George
knocks it away from Mitchell inside the
dish in the bucket all the injuries they
just had to find somebody and he was out
there shot blocked by Hera who come
bucks every good number six on the shot
clock
Beverly Wow so lead to form well he'll
drive miss baguette pound will go to the
line they won 229 this and a steal by
Paul George these guys are so good with
their hands Schroeder bit by Leonard
trying to get a screen he gets around if
he drives has it knocked out of bounds
Beal goes flying he can't believe a foul
wasn't called here's Durant good hands
by montrezl Harrell he's been one of the
best bench players in the league this
year Harris ball deflected the wrapper
off hasn't a defense
Beverly gets it back hit it
there yeah I'm gonna tell you he's in
super 20 home there's a steel foot race
barrel talents to the bastions Laura
so many years the Lakers are very good
whatever story that another block that
was good just Alexander rejecting the
big seven footers or in recent years the
Clippers very good the Lakers very fast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so really slowly wants to have any
chance in this game and we're gonna get
off in front of you I'm feeling right
now what a pass it back down to a
10-point deficit curry beautiful fast
money has it rejected by Harold
I'm very very well against that says so
far answering every call there is a
steal by Beverly join great respect to
the shot-blocker motley inside we just
came in to replace Gallinari and quickly
he scores a bucket against Turner but
George has gone for 36 37 and 43 in his
last three runs and they're
demonstrating that he's one of the top
two way players in the league comes up
with the steal
Ferguson got it Jen I remember it like
it's yesterday did the game as to why
Leonard takes it away
he's got Lowery Alfred laid it pretty
well until they reach almost had the
steal the JA clock put behind by Harrell
and Succot rejected early game when you
shoot your three-pointers brick to the
corner turn and shoot at three anybody
can hit a set shot that's how you become
a lead Beverly with the pick save Gil
just Alexander with Mariah
[Applause]
27 to 31 excuse me after that last make
your correct rosin with the rebound
Spurs up by one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
DeRozan at midcourt was waiting for
these to clear out and finally made a
decision that was last touched there's a
deflection and a turnover charge I've
instead studied in ketchup
roll
[Applause]
it's one to go there off the steal in
transition
Munson runs the other way runs out of
the room and runs into Harrell who
throws it down Ward to that he changes
each night at halftime everybody I don't
know how he does it felt that that's his
deal Oh Beverly temple hard to the
basket trumpet oh my god oh but it
really is the the guards fault working
with you moving too soon or too late
Gallinari to a hole snuffed away
recovers it of somehow scores it mass
deflected by George Burton which the
pass force plenty of time you leave a
high percentage three-point shooter open
like they get on that let's swap by
Kawhi about that defense put the bigger
stronger Chandler on
nice pulled away by patrick beverley it
magma dreamless one fly by what's off
the dependent drives his goal true to
trying to dribble the ball flat waiting
for the screen ears left
taken away by Jackson the heat with
numbers George the only one back trying
to affect the shallow g-man oh man
flippers by three can't save it though
out of bounds to go to the nets
let's Brooke backdoor Grant inside
layered with a big defensive play and
the block for Toronto what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content